[Music]
everybody welcome back to ask mr.
wonderful another fantastic episode
about to happen you know I love to
collaborate with people particularly
wants to travel all around the world
because all of our questions are global
these days we get them from everywhere
and that's exactly who I've got today
welcome Eric Conover your kind of
legendary on YouTube already you built a
little franchise here running around all
over the place tell us your story so the
short version I started YouTube about
four years ago kind of just dipping my
feet and I had no experience in video
making or editing who did exactly I
taught myself actually by YouTube how to
edit these little videos and at the
start they were just horrible kind of
unwatchable to be honest the majority
and then slowly but surely I got better
at filmmaking and editing and built out
a luxury lifestyle travel brand it's
interesting
so you hhor-- of your content you have
to travel so I'm gonna take you love
doing it right yeah I mean traveling I
grew up right outside of Atlantic City
in southern New Jersey a middle-class
family but we had never travelled my
first time on a plane I was 24 you gotta
be kidding yeah well you're shaking in
your boots excited as I could be I
remember my first time but I was very
very young it never ceases to amaze me I
just love flying around but obviously if
you're going to be doing this what how
you curate where you're going where do
you know you want to go next because I'm
assuming your base wants to know what's
next for you exactly so there's a few
ways how I kind of build out this
schedule first off its places that I
think that my audience would find
interesting did they want to go - yeah
exactly I haven't been there yet yeah in
places that I have a little you know a
bucket list as well that I so crazy
chicken places more or less yes all
right
you go there you shoot and I assume at
the end of the day I would want to watch
you because you're learning something
and you're teaching me about it at the
same time that's what you're doing
you're curating travel that's right
we've been wildly successful at it yeah
I like to think that traveling it
started as a passion and then it slowly
turned into the biz
so I didn't go into it looking to build
out a travel business and have the
guides going out it was more or less
just because I had the passion to travel
and then the rest kind of happened
naturally now every time I get a
successful youtuber like you on people
ask questions about how do you sustain
it how do you maintain it is this what
your passion is in terms of being an
entrepreneur how are you gonna grow it
what's the game plan are you willing to
share some secrets with all of those
that want to become you yeah I mean
listen in the beginning there wasn't a
game plan at all to be totally honest
kind of just flying by the seat of my
pants but really in the past two years
I've developed a five-year plan where I
really want to take this and you know
that's a very big period of time five
years so what are your revenue streams
did you focus on your with your time yes
so right now it is Adsense through
YouTube of course I've already starts
with that base yeah exactly and and it
depends on your content right some of
the creators who have content that isn't
so family-friendly they have been hit
hard with the new policies that YouTube
has put in place but my content is
trapped Society is forcing that on
everybody I mean that's what people want
I mean look from it from a creative
artists point of view I can I can see
them calling it censorship on the other
hand it's the reality that we live in
yes they have been hit hard obviously
you are very family-friendly in what you
do so you don't have that problem that's
right so ad census is definitely up
there that means other advertisers are
interested in you because you're not
going to offend anybody right correct
that's good business yeah I mean the
past year I really went into the brand
partnerships just because the
opportunities are endless right and then
use an agency to find them when you're
doing it yourself I would say 90% is
inbound to my inbox then the other 10%
is through agencies recently I started
working with a larger agency that is
more rooted in traditional media just to
expand opportunities so they can be
actively pitching my brand rather than
having it just be inbound opportunities
you know when you're negotiating the
deal yourself how do you price yourself
because you don't have the benefit of
all the data the agency has you're just
weighing it out there it's interesting
you say that because for I would say the
majority of people out there it's the
Wild West like you no one knows their
rate their worth and there's actually a
few services
that you can sign up for and pay a
monthly price one of them is social
Bluebook and i recently went on their
you link your YouTube account to their
algorithm they go through your views
your comments your likes demographics
everything and they come out with a
range of a price point based on others
that are doing the same thing that and
then with the data from YouTube itself
so say I'm getting six million views a
month
I have 75% mail that live in New York
Los Angeles the UK those are highly
desired regions and demographics so
based on that then they make a price
range and you think the market looks at
that when you give it to them and say
look I price my stuff this way here's
the date of the pack setup that's why
you're gonna pay 10 cents of you 5 cents
of you whatever it is you're negotiating
for what about the brand endorsements
inside of what you do so that's your
third revenue stream or you have you
figured out a way to use your brand and
sell it in other ways that's what I'm
developing currently as far as building
out a brand that comes from my audience
that has the same passions as me that
would support this new brand them
actually launching in the next two
months it's very exciting
another question everybody asks about
guys to travel like you because I travel
a lot too
how does that work with you a
relationship because you're not around
much I'm fortunate enough that my
girlfriend actually comes on a lot of my
trips that's pretty good yeah it's I
mean it's pretty much ideal doubles your
cost it does but I'm also very lucky
that my girlfriend Hannah you know she
feeds my creativity as well as I feed
her so having her with me on the road a
second voice exactly that's cool
sometimes to silence my voice other
times to bring it up in certain
instances but it's well that works and
build that into your relationship then
it's you know all things to all people I
mean so many people in the YouTube world
want to get to where you are where
you're basically free you're if you're
an entrepreneur that's been successful
and now your time is as you decide to
spend it which is a remarkable thing in
life is an entrepreneur do you feel
you've achieved your goal because
entrepreneurship is a desire for
personal freedom it's not necessarily
money it's to decide how you want to
spend your time very few people in life
get to decide on their own particularly
at your age how they're going to spend
every minute of the day I'm assume
you've got there now
I have it's actually very interesting I
worked a traditional nine-to-five job
before I did this so I truly know how
that feels to how that sucks to have
someone tell you when you can go to the
bathroom when you can eat when you can
come and go and I have been very
fortunate to build out a life where my
schedule is truly how I want to shape it
which is the ultimate freedom but at the
same time you know how it is you have to
have that mentality to structure your
day because no one's telling you how to
do it which means you're probably
working harder than you're ever worked
before so the perception of freedom is
you get to work as hard as you want but
you're just spending more time working
basically that's right that is the
definition of on there the day is kind
of blend together because there is no
set schedule because you know you could
have a project with a client that is in
Asia and you're in New York so it's the
next day for them on a Monday and it's
Sunday night and you have to finish and
edit so the day is kind of do blend
together and it is working I would say
you can't even really quantify how much
harder you work when you work for
yourself versus a company and I think
that's a good message everybody actually
watching this because launch Premiership
is desire for almost everybody except
not everybody can do it because it's so
brutal on your time it is really
something that just consumes your life
and if you can't handle that then you
shouldn't try it exactly that's fair
message but I would have any other way
yeah I get that but look I really admire
anybody who can do what you've done
because I know how hard it is in the
future of this business model you're
working on this five-year plan is
international a big part of it are you
gonna continue to actually do more and
more outside of the US it is building up
the the luxury travel sector is a very
very large part of this plan so working
with that means you're gonna be hitting
the road big-time yes
the 22-hour flight yes that's right I
mean because Asia is becoming a big part
of the story the Middle East is actually
emerging in some ways for tourism those
are long hauls they are even I went to
the Philippines
last spring long trip 30-something hours
of travel yeah yeah and how risky do you
feel after that like it must be tough to
grind yourself into shooting some videos
it's interesting because the gel I just
wears away when you get to a beautiful
destination and you look around and you
see
these sites that you've dreamed of when
you were kid and you kind of get that
second wind and you just you're ready to
go that's fantastic
all right let's go into the questions
I'm glad I've got you because we're
gonna hear from different people all
kinds of different questions and I want
you to bring your perspective to it
that's what I love about ask mr.
wonderful when we collaborate sky's the
limit and just tell the truth you ready
to go let's do it here's something from
Samantha D what's the worst job you've
ever had and how did you know it was
very apropos to what we're just talking
about what's the worst job you've ever
had the worst job ever had actually took
place I'm not even kidding you a block
away from where we're filming right now
really today I won't say the name but it
was a luxury hotel in New York City and
this was when I was starting youtube so
I took on a job that paid the bills but
I could still have the throat were you
doing for the hotel I was working at the
front desk so just checking people in
but as my youtube grew I slowly demoted
myself to free it more time to pursue
YouTube so by the end of it I was
working at the pool as a certified
lifeguard at the pool
rolling towels and handing them to these
guests you were basically asking the
guys that running the hotel probably
liking your work saying demote me demote
me demote me it's interesting at the
time no one even knew I was doing it at
work I kind of kept it you know under
wraps and at this time it was very early
on so I didn't really have my brand
built I needed more free time exactly
okay so why was that the worst job you
ever had
trading your time for money is one of
the worst things you can ever do
especially when it's not that much money
yeah no kidding thank you at that time
back well I think it's important that it
was the motivational tool that you used
on yourself to set yourself free look at
it that way you saw how tough it can be
I had a similar experience I only had
one real job I worked for a woman who
owned a ice cream store called Magoo's
in a mall and hired me as a scraper you
know for a scoop of ice cream and then
she said one day scraped the gum off the
floor and I said no I'm a scooper not a
scraper and she said how about this
you're fired and that's when I realized
how the whole world work there's people
that own the store and there's
people that scraped the [ __ ] off the
floor and you have to decide which
direction you want to go scrapers aren't
bad if you like scraping I don't like
scraping so that was the end of that and
it you know I think it's been a good
path but I've realized it's been hard
it's a great question to start this
journey with because it is a decision
about entrepreneurship and freedom in
some ways and you've made your decision
but I bet you've had some tough times
along the way I mean more than I can
even recall yeah so I mean you can
relate to this even especially the
beginning when you start anything is
always the hardest it's an inverse
pyramid there are so many people trying
to go up to this one tiny top and
everyone's at the bottom kind of clawing
through that and a lot of people stop
and I think I truly believe one of them
you don't want to step on the moon I
step on them on the way up you got to be
careful exactly but I think it's the
people who just keep going that
ultimately succeeded yeah you got to
keep going if you believe in it it's
great advice keep that thought let's
move on we're going to hear from you
just never know what you're gonna get
it's a box of chocolates
here's Jake mr. O'Leary in the workforce
how do you distinguish between talent
that will excel and individuals that
will not in particular is there any
correlation between individuals that
come from a more privileged background
having less motivation or less
probability to succeed than those that
have to quote unquote earn their way I
like that there's a class question in
there too
how you gonna answer that one that's a
tough one because I I don't believe that
there is talent exists in certain fields
especially you know athletics but I
think that hard work will always beat
talent of talents not working hard it's
kind of I guess what you're saying yeah
but as far as the class question it's
tough because I only have my own
experiences to call from I really don't
think there's the a distinguishing
factor there I think if you come from a
less privileged background you might
have that drive to then change your
circumstances where you started where
I'm from it's it's a very small town
four thousand people everyone works you
know normal and they know each other and
they know each other so I do see that
aspect of it
it's tough to kind of get out of there I
left home when I was 17 but then on the
other side if someone is from a more
privileged background they could get too
comfortable get too soft but then at the
same time they can see how they got to
that point or how their parents got them
to that point it all depends on work
ethic yeah I think you just nailed it
for me it is work ethic because people
work for different reasons if you're
already wealthy and you're somehow
you've ended up with a trust fund or
something work is there to define who
you are there's nothing worse than being
listless and rich because people look at
you say what are you doing with your
life they don't have an answer now
there's not many people like that
the other attribute I found that I've
learned over experience is this great
talent and great people that have you
know deliver results in their lives know
how to work with others they know how to
work on teams even if they're running
the company people respect them and
that's very hard to do if you don't have
the ability to work with people you have
a very hard time in life and the way I
manifest that in my business is I've got
a lot of investments and a lot of
companies and I've been an operator and
I'm an investor now and I guess a mentor
in some ways and I say look if you're
gonna have to make a big hire put them
on a program for six months that gives
them a chance to prove themselves with
all the people around them in other
words say look we're gonna try this for
six months it doesn't work out both of
us go our separate ways and everything's
good and that way you're not setting
yourself up for failure on either side
and I've learned that to be a very very
good way of integrating people into
businesses and determining whether
they're going to work or they don't and
it's not a bad thing if it doesn't work
out it's much worse to bring them in
making the assumption all will be great
in six months and then all of a sudden
you've got to terminate a relationship
that's worse than falling in love if you
think about it you hurt everybody in the
business and that's worked for me and
that's what I tell people hire slowly
fire quickly that's what I do
I will take that advice that applies to
my current situation in life that's very
very good advice yeah it works it really
works and you'll find that it gives
everybody a chance to motivate
themselves to make it happen six months
a long time yeah it really is you'll
prove everything that way good question
though
Mason Graham let's hear from Mason hey
mr. wonderful thanks for listening to my
message
this is Mason from Albuquerque New
Mexico and I recently got let go for my
job as a video specialist for a
marketing firm and I've been working in
the marketing industry for about two or
three years now making online video ads
and different types of creatives and I
found that I actually really have a
passion for it since I'm also a guitar
player and an artist and I do a lot of
stuff in the visual and musical space
but now that I'm unemployed I find
myself struggling to start back up again
I've always dreamed of being an
entrepreneur but since I worked at 9 to
5 for so long I kind of got caught up in
the security and now I'm 24 and the risk
seems kind of daunting but it's still
something that I really really dream
about doing right at the cusp you know
I'm gonna let you start with this one
because this guy is much closer to your
age than mine and you probably can
connect with him pretty easily you know
he was very happy 9 to 5 then he wants
to break out and he realizes ain't so
easy yeah the first thing I would say is
24 is still very young I just turned 30
and looking at an old man I take it back
looking back at 24 that's six that's six
years that's a long time like here we're
talking about this five year plan I have
that's I'll be 35 that's a good amount
of time I would say you have to take the
risk now there's no other time to take
it especially if you've been let go from
this company I think you could look back
at this as the greatest opportunity that
he ever had it's fair to say that I know
it's it's it's always a challenge though
to make that leap it's but you have to
do it you have to jump over the
waterfall that's personally you got to
do it the one thing I would say to
somebody who's in the creative arts
because videography editing producing as
we are doing in these YouTube
experiments and you know businesses in
your case it's fantastic you have to let
others know if you're going to sell your
services that way that you're good at it
which means you've got to generate a
if you were coming to me and saying look
I want to do some videography for you
mr. O'Leary and one of your companies I
love to hear from you but I want to see
your work I want to see what you can do
and you can do that online just send me
a link of all your stuff and let me
peruse it I actually came up as an
editor film editor years and years and
years ago for the Olympics and I still
keep my editing talents because I like
the chops I think it helps you you know
do the things we love to do and today
everything's video and everything's kind
of how can you communicate visually so
if you're going to market yourself
Mayson get a reel and start to get
social behind you and start you know be
like a peacock show your stuff strut
around that's how you get gigs wouldn't
you say the one thing I'll add to that
is you have to have the mentality that
it's already your job so Mason you're
just starting out with this you have to
have the mentality that you already you
already are really this and you're good
at it and you have to just show the
world and like you said build the
following and just put yourself out
there yeah I totally agree I mean I love
to work with creative editors and
videographers and always giving new
people a chance because you never know
you're gonna discover something great
but if you can't see it you can't sell
it that's the way I look at it in this
business
alright that was interesting let's hear
from Christopher Poe all right
Christopher what do you got
hey mr. wonderful so I have a quick
question for you what's more important
to you time money or health I always
thank you whoa that's a good one
talk about a Zen moment first oh you're
going first buddy time money or health
usually health gotta be right easily I
had a few experiences in the past year
where my health was jeopardized while
traveling I got the worst case of food
poisoning well my life of course and
what you're doing you're all over the
place eating when stuff you don't even
know it was so bad I had to cancel a
trip cut it short it was a month long
trip that ended up being two weeks he
just couldn't kick it it was it was that
I couldn't finish a hike without
actually passing out dehydration that's
what hydration just muscle soreness but
health is the ultimate that really put
my health back
on track and I actually ended up ended
up being the best thing that happened in
2019 because then it facilitated a
challenge video I did that ended up
turning into a collaboration with Chris
Hemsworth the actor who launched a
fitness app so that you know that issue
of the health kind of turned into being
the blessing in disguise but there's two
others on the hit parade there's time
and money where do you rank and you got
to rank them here's the deal
money is last time is the second time is
second that's very insightful I'm gonna
look at it this way I have to agree with
you on health and you know what I've
realized because I've got a lot of
friends that are running into health
issues you got to live your life you
know honoring your body because it's
it's your vessel and if you you know
drink too much you take drugs or
anything like that I'm getting it to a
thing now about diet and great foods and
sleep and and and and that just gives
you more energy so I totally agree
time and money that's interesting
because you could argue that money buys
you time to do things that you want to
do it doesn't get you more time but it
gets you in a place where you can spend
your time in ways you want but I don't
want to be I'm gonna rank him slightly
differently I'm going to say health
hundred percent agree with you there
then I'm gonna go number two on money
because I am going to say that money if
you pursue it not for the greed of money
but the pursuit of freedom lets you
spend your time in the way you want to
but that is probably Christopher post
question is probably one of the best
I've had on ask mr. wonderful this guy
is really screwing with me now when I
think about it that's very insightful I
do see your side of that yeah I mean
it's really in life health yes time and
money may be loved in there somewhere
loves in there yeah he didn't ask about
love but maybe that's the fourth thing
probably in the bottom of the list at
the end of the day that's the problem oh
I don't want to be negative
let's go to Brian
H good morning mr. O'Leary this is Brian
from Austin
yeah 27 years old and after a few years
of professional mediocrity I've set new
goals for myself I want to build a net
worth of 300 million dollars and have
decided I want to do that through real
estate investment and property
management as well as having a couple of
serious creative business ideas into
this distilled spirits business and the
therapeutic and healthcare services
business I'm becoming a licensed real
estate agent to begin my path but what
would your advice be to someone that
plans to build nine figures of wealth
through real estate and business
ownership B Wow like I've heard of
ambition but 300 million that means
you've got to make 450 million pre-tax
to end up with that that's some serious
stuff I love how you think what do you
think on this one it's tough because I
can't I can't answer to that but I don't
have a net worth of 300 million dollars
either does he that is true I would say
to to you have your long-term goal but
break it down into what can I do today
this week this month then this year and
slowly put those steps into place and
really build out a plan and then ask
yourself why that number I'm sure that
he has some reasons behind that number
but I think just planning it out on the
smaller level and then slowly getting
wider and wider so I'm gonna answer that
question in a different way first of all
Brian you're not going to get to 300
million dollars with a plan to be in
multiple sectors at the same time that
ain't going to happen
if you think you can make it in real
estate you got to focus on real estate
you got to make your first turn on that
and you have to prove that you can make
the first million that's hard to do it's
next to impossible for most people but
to get to 300 million you've got to be
very very focused and understand and
become very competitive in one sector
where you have a competitive advantage
knowledge and experience and you know
the ability to deliver on these but to
actually do all of those things that's
not going to work by the way you don't
need three hundred million dollars the
difference between having 50 and 300 is
not a lot to be honest with you you can
buy more [ __ ] that you don't need and a
whole lot of houses and I've learned
with houses if you can't spend 90 days
there you shouldn't own it you should
rent it so basically can only own four
houses three
a ton of money you should be happy with
50 million
you should be happy with 10 million you
should be happy with 1 million call me
when you get to a million I'm gonna
bring it back for more questions and ask
you how tough it was to get that great
question though I love ambition 300
million that's [ __ ] crazy but yeah
geez it's it's fantastic Brian I love
you that's so nuts
remember it's 450 before tax so don't
focus on 300 but watch your head and you
gotta get 450 that's half a billion
rounded out half a billion good luck if
by you got half a billion you get a
sports team in there somewhere all right
Charles oh you know I love these
questions they're crated you know
they're real who we're talking about 350
million dollars the guy's upset me I'm
just thinking about it all right hello
mr. wonderful
do us a favor please show us the watch
you wear during your episodes and
explain you know just a minute or so
explain what the watch is I've been
following your watch journey and I
always wonder what you're wearing what
exactly are you wearing that episode
thank you
that's interesting well you know Eric we
started our conversation at the first
thing we start talking about were
watches right because I looked at that
on your wrist and said what is that how
did you get that that is not an Apple
watch you're not wearing consumer
electronics why are you wearing that
watch this watch it's a raid Oh Captain
Cook I worked with this company Rado
last year did some research they are a
Swiss company and to be honest I just
like these I like the aesthetic it's a
sports looking face it's a travel watch
in some ways it's very clean face it's
beautiful it looks terrific and it's of
the ilk of the steel watch craze that's
everywhere around the world today I'm a
huge watch collector so I love a
question like this I could go on for
hours I won't but I always travel with
two or three watches every day and I try
and bring two themes into my style of
watches one is going to be gold or off
gold and the other would be silver so
today by happenchance I have this is a
ap their new series called the code
11:59 perpetual there's only 100 of
these made in the world I wanted to
be one of those owners is the only one
in the world with a red band on it
everybody knows I wear red bands for
continuity on television but this is a
very complicated watch the face is
rather remarkable is not a simple dial
it's a complicated one and it works well
with gold jewelry gold tie pin maybe or
whatever in the red band but I also
today I'm travelling with a classic and
the steel face blue face huge theme out
there this is a Vassar all overseas
which is a classic watch very crisp and
clean very much like what you're wearing
on your wrist there so I can change from
a sporty look to a more conservative one
later tonight when I go to a dinner I'm
having with an ambassador so this is a
this is what I'll be wearing tonight
I'll probably wear this for some Porsche
in the afternoon and I just like to wear
different watch that's interesting you
travel with you said three generally
three today I have two because I'm only
going to be away for two days so I I
usually wear three watches in one day
morning noon and night I have so many
watches if I don't wear them they get
upset you know watch has a soul you got
to wear it but these are the two I'm
traveling with right now I love this
piece but you know they're all they all
have stories and I think if your watch
collector and you get this disease it
better be after you make 350 million
dollars because these things are really
expensive but they're great investments
to my watch collection because I'm an
investor I track its market value every
day it's up 28% over last year
certain pieces have gone up more than
others but I like to do it that way
anyways I thought this was really
interesting you brought a whole
different dynamic this Travel freedom
thing you've got but you have a hard
road ahead you're gonna travel millions
of miles on this five-year journey
mm-hmm I would say that when I look at
you know what I've done on YouTube it's
not even the tip of the iceberg of what
I aim to do it's it's very much so the
beginning and it's gonna change a ton in
the next few years but yeah there is a
lot left to do a lot of miles to travel
a lot of video is to make but when you
start it I want to leave on this concept
because I'm sure this happened to you
five-year plans are great ideas but
shifts going to
happen you know that what do you think
about your ability to pivot I think the
one thing you have to do on YouTube to
survive is to pivot I think that when I
first set out to do this I gave myself
five years in New York I said if I can
work for myself in five years that was
my level of success the the idea of time
if I could manage all my time in five
years I made it that's success I've set
new benchmarks that I have to measure
but throughout that five years the
pivots were enormous even in the past
I've really gotten into luxury real
estate on my channel that's I think that
is the biggest series now second to the
travel is torn these multimillion-dollar
properties how are you getting access to
them is that is your notoriety on
YouTube getting access to these and they
want to market them they want you to go
through them it's an interesting story
because it was travel that got me the
first access point which was through
Ryan Serhant the realtor he was going to
Africa had some questions so he was
starting a channel we had a meeting I
said hey Ryan let me have access to one
of your most expensive listings I'll
film a tour put on my channel I know
those do well it got five million views
just to get access to see something as
crazy as that house yeah and then from
there kind of snowballed and now it's at
the point where people are reaching out
every day even just people looking to
sell their properties to then list them
with me and I'm getting to that process
of actually so that is a total pivot you
created a new business platform that's
exactly what happened there exactly
that's very good that's just the example
of you you kind of have to adapt on
YouTube to certain trends but still stay
true to yourself through travel I love
staying in different hotels living
spaces seeing how places make me because
that mean you're gonna step into
ownership and real estate about to buy
something I can sense that that's the
big goal for 2020 is my girlfriend I to
purchase a loft and do a big renovation
series well I want to tell you something
right now as mr. wonderful I forbid you
to do that unless you get married
because that's a huge asset and no
prenup you mean you've got to be
together you got to be you got to force
yourselves together so I'm telling you
right now do not buy that place and let
you get married
that's straight advice then you buy it
after you're married and then you have
to live together with the huge asset the
mortgage and everything else but so many
disastrous of people that are dating
that by real-estate I forbid you will be
married by then very good really enjoy
it there if that was fantastic
thank you listen that was terrific I
love I love giving up marital advice is
just terrific I love that too
so anyways until next time thank you so
much great questions on ask mr.
wonderful this week Eric you were
terrific thank you so much
ciao